- I wish I did this seven years ago.
I wish I got to see the last seven years,
every minute, every day,
always, forever.
(droning electronic music)
- [AJ] 0 and 5 without Melo this year.
- [Gary] It's good.
- Yeah, sticks a pipe in the
we're better off without Melo argument.
This version of Melo. That passes.
(emotional electronic music)
- Two overtime losses to decent teams.
Houston and Oklahoma City without Melo.
- [AJ] Yeah.
- You were there for both.
Oh no, I was (mumbling).
- I was there for (mumbling).
- We were both (mumbling).
Three minutes for me.
- [AJ] Okay, no problem.
I'll go see what he needs.
- Yeah, go see if he needs.
(emotional electronic music)
(people talking in background)
Whoever you guys deem as
the five to seven people
that need to know first
is something that I think we can do today.
I don't think at this point (bleep) knows
and you telling them
and they're your friends
is for you to tell them today.
Unless I'm wrong.
I'm kinda shooting the shit here.
You know what I mean?
Met with Matt Higgins,
our business partner,
the guy who drove the former
President of the Jets,
drove the transaction for Steve Ross,
owner of the Dolphins,
'cause he works with him now,
to buy the piece of VaynerMedia.
and as my partner Vayner/RSE.
Best dude, brother.
Hello.
- Hey (mumbling) Gary, how are you?
- [Gary] I'm well, how are you?
- I am quite well, thank you, yourself?
- I'm doing well.
How are you?
- Good. Good.
- Great, will be very good.
My major concern, as ever,
is keeping your answers
as full as possible.
- Yes, in this new system.
- Exactly.
- Yep, makes sense.
- Keeping all the things
that are in the book
without being a repetition of the book,
being you.
- No, I think that's right.
I think the thing we did
with the bullet points,
I think reading 'em, putting
a couple bullet points,
lends it to more depth, less hyperbole.
And so I think that will work.
- Let's make sure we keep on doing that.
- DailyVee is not monetized, Ram.
It's free content to teach people
the way that I would learn,
which is, I wouldn't learn by reading.
I would learn by watching.
And so the #AskGaryVee show is very
kind of prescription, kind of like,
here is the direct answer.
I've been very happy reading the comments
of DailyVee for the people
that are built like me,
which is like, "I just learned something."
And for 90% of you, you didn't see it,
but for the 10% that learn the way I do,
they picked up on a
cadence or way I said it
or how I done it.
It's been really cool.
It's really cool to make a show
that would've helped the 16-year-old me.
And that's what DailyVee is for me.
That's how I would have learned.
I learn by watching.
I learn by watching everybody.
And we're going really, it's why
we're pushing it so hard.
E-mail subject line, bam, Derek Hull,
talks about that.
That was one little thing that
I may have never gotten to
in AskGary or honestly,
there's been like three or
four people that e-mailed me
that are pretty big in the game
and they said, "Here's the weirdest thing
"I've learned from you.
"You're actually nice to people,
"like when you're at the
airport or your driver.
"Like somebody in the elevator,
"I thought I was a big
shot and I wasn't as nice
"and you're way bigger than me
"and that kind of punched me in the gut."
I know that you were excited about that
'cause you know how I rolled and you were,
I knew that.
Without even knowing any of
the first couple GaryVee's
were gonna have that, DailyVee's,
'cause I was like, "I know
DRock wants the world to know
"that I'm a nice guy."
(mumbling)
- And here's his question.
You should just hear it
and then while you're hearing that,
take a look at your
notes there.
- [Gary] Yeah, it's long.
- [Rick] It's long and you gotta
include Gone With the Wind.
- [Gary] You got it, right, got it.
- [Voiceover] Hey guys, wassup,
this Draymond Green, four for
the Golden State Warriors,
and I am super-excited about readin'
the next 10 questions in
the AskGaryVee book to ya.
Thanks a lot for havin' me.
You know I much appreciate it.
How do I create interesting content
for a boring product or a stale industry?
- I'm gonna read the first part because
that has to be there.
- [Rick] Got it.
- A white lawyer defends a black man
in a small Southern town.
A spoiled rich girl
gets married three times
and survives the Civil War.
Boy meets girl.
Recognize any of these?
Shaved down to their core,
To Kill a Mockingbird, Gone With the Wind,
and Romeo and Juliet
sound pretty damn boring.
Their lasting power lies in fresh,
imaginative, daring,
surprising storytelling
of their creators.
There is no boring if
you tell the right story.
- [Rick] If you tell the story right.
- There is no boring if
you tell your story right.
What really gets me
excited about this question
is (laughing) just living my life.
For so many years, people
came up to me and said,
"Gary, you're so lucky, though."
Especially with Crush It! and
as my brand was building,
"You're so lucky Gary.
"You have wine.
"That's an interesting category.
"That's why you were successful."
Which you know, if you know me,
that pissed me off to no end
because I wanted to remind people
that before me, really before me,
wine was held in a very
esteemed place in the U.S.
People talk down to people about it.
If anything, people were
intimidated about wine.
Yeah, there was a small subset,
normally in the affluent world,
of people that were intrigued by wine,
but the people that I was reaching
and the people that were
getting excited about wine
and getting excited about me,
these were beer drinkers.
These were 23-year-old dudes,
these were 31-year-old females
that have never been
exposed to the wine world.
They thought about wine
three times a year,
Thanksgiving, this, that,
and the other thing.
It wasn't that interesting.
It's just I created interest around it.
And if you look back,
if you look at Jim Cramer,
is that really interesting?
Is Wall Street interesting to people
that don't care about
making money on Wall Street?
The answer is no.
And I can break down everything,
including things that we've accepted,
like sports and music.
By the way, I'm not that
interested in music,
but Casey Kasem in the morning
as a kid on radio got me excited about it.
If you know how to story-tell,
especially if you have two things.
Listen to me and listen to me good.
And this is a very, very important
part of this audio book.
If you have passion,
like you really love it,
like you really love it
and, because a lot of
you love a lotta things,
and you have expertise,
if ya really know it.
Everybody knew I had passion
with Wine Library TV.
What everybody forgot is
the day I started that show,
I had been in that industry
for more than half my life,
that at 14, 15, 16, and 17 years old,
before I was 30, when I started the show,
I was reading The Wine
Spectator, becoming educated,
that from 21 to 30, I
was tasting and drinking
50 wines a day,
buying for one of the biggest
companies in the country,
becoming deeply educated.
So when I had all my
charisma and I was excited,
I could also have the chops for the people
that actually cared about learning.
If you have those two things, you can win,
whether you're building jet engines,
if you're doing carpeting.
I'm looking at the carpet
right now as I read this.
I'm bored as hell with
carpets, but I promise you,
if you're listening right now,
and you are passionate about carpets,
you know interior design.
If you don't think that you can make
a Snapchat or Instagram or YouTube show
that explodes your carpet business,
well then, you're not paying attention
to what's happened over the last 10 years,
and more importantly, what's gonna happen
over the next 10 years.
There is absolutely no boring product
if you're actually in business.
Let me say that again.
There is absolutely no boring product
if you're actually in business.
If people are buying it,
they have an interest.
Maybe it's not the most
interesting thing in the world.
They have an interest
about saving money on it,
using it properly.
It may be a utility, not an entertainment,
but if you're lucky enough
to be selling a utility,
something people need,
and if you can just add a
little bit of entertainment,
then you've got gold.
That was awesome.
- [Rick] That was great, thank you.
- DRock, I want that.
- [Rick] That was good.
- I want that whole thing.
I'm so pumped you're here.
I want that whole thing.
That's gonna give depth.
That's like the best answer I gave
on this damn book so far.
Yo.
(mumbling)
- [Gary] Sup bro.
- [Man] Make the show today?
- You're gonna make the DailyVee.
- What's goin' on.
- [Man] I did the Snapchat in your honor.
- DV 11, I love it.
(laughing)
- [Matt] Yo.
- [Gary] Yo.
- [Matt] What's happenin'?
- [Gary] It's happenin'.
- [Voiceover] That's what I figured.
(laughing)
- I get it.
- That was so weird.
- [AJ] That was cool.
- Okay, so this is for (bleep).
Fuckin' can't get away from that thing.
- It's a beast.
Only one on there?
- Cop.
Okay.
- You know, it's funny.
It's 9:54
in the evening.
First, Mike's now following me around.
You'll be seeing Mike a lot more
because we're on a 12-week.
Are we on a 12-week, Mike?
- [Mike] 12-week fat loss.
- 12-week fat loss.
Gonna get gnarly,
really cut up.
So that should be fun.
So there'll be more Mike
on the DailyVee show.
But figuring that this episode
is a little tricky to create a narrative.
I was even about to tell you, DRock,
maybe we don't even run an episode
on days where there's like,
not an exact thing.
But I think we'll air this.
We'll see how it goes.
I feel like this is my opportunity
to like do rants,
like when there's episodes.
(mumbling)
That's alright.
I love when it's dark.
I'll try to give ya some more light.
Woo, look, DRock.
I got your back, oh look, DRock.
I got your back.
I hate that we care about lighting now.
100%.
- [Man] We're gettin' your
last one then, before I turn...
(laughing)
- But you know what I mean?
100, I think there's a deal to be done.
Because I think there's a discount from me
'cause I wouldn't do it otherwise.
And I'm hoping in that
discount, you guys get excited.
That's what I think.
- [Man] Yup, thanks Gary, appreciate it.
- Alright, keep talkin'.
(mumbling)
Yo.
Where am I goin', right here?
Oh, with you?
- With me, yeah.
- Great, what is it?
- So we're gonna announce
Slack officially.
- Alright, let's do it.
What's up everybody.
This is Gary Vaynerchuk, your CEO.
Unlike normal times where I stick around
and kinda pander to whatever
the other person has to say about this,
I'm leaving because I
think Alex can handle this,
mainly 'cause most of
you don't know who he is.
That's why I'm here,
to make you realize, it's
a VaynerMedia video.
Alex, take it away.
- Alright, thanks for (mumbling).
- [DRock] Are you walking away?
- He's gonna walk away.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [DRock] I need that mic.
- Okay. That's alright, keep playin'.
Fine, I'll sit, go fast.
(laughing)
- Cool, so...
Facebook stock exploded,
after-hour earnings.
I haven't read it yet.
But I'm excited about that.
I will end up being historically correct
on Facebook for sure.
Snapchat will follow that as well.
We've been talking a
lot about those things.
Ari, Marcus, I think what we need to do is
get a lot more information here,
which I'll let you guys do
and get more of what the KPI's are.
It's a general awareness, engagement.
This part, I think, I'm very comfortable
with the four people that are on the call.
And then kind of use me as the backstop
to the production of video costs
against this to drive down the overhead.
So we can come into an
attractive price for (bleep).
- Everyone walks in in the morning
and it's more TMZ-style.
The walk to the door and your day is,
"What do we do today
"because two hours ago
something hit the news
"and what (bleep) do we say about it?"
- That's interesting.
(mumbling)
- And you build pillars that give you,
you gotta build pillars that give you
permission to go there.
Like if you have a weekly podcast,
you can go there.
- [Man] Yeah, so it's like someone
walks in the door (mumbling).
- You can't just tweet it all
of a sudden and be like...
- [Man] My job's to do the podcast
instead of my job's to think about my
point of sale when I
gotta get out the door
for first focus.
- That's right.
(mumbling)
- [Man] That's what (bleeps).
- That's exactly right.
- [Man] They basically
allocated human resource.
- Well, they weren't even different.
They have an entire PNL.
They're tryin' to run the
thing as a profit center,
which is right.
- [Man] Cheers.
- Cheers, to good health.
Good health, guys.
Had some great client meetings
in the last couple days.
Tomorrow's an intense day,
flying in, flying out to Tennessee.
So that should be a
pretty interesting day.
Four hours delay this morning
because of fog in Knoxville.
And then my pilot got appendicitis.
We finally took off and then
the fog didn't clear in Knoxville.
So we had to land in Chattanooga.
So now I'm just gonna sit
in the Chattanooga airport,
do the 90-minute call with a client
who's been amazing.
Thank you for that, Dave.
And I'm gonna get right back
in a plane and fly back.
9:54 PM, now going to another meeting.
I was intrigued by the
first three or four episodes
of people quantifying how hard I work
or putting in the hours.
This has been unbelievably interesting.
Back to the rant I did
in the booth reading my book.
I realized what DailyVee,
and I'm just reading all
the comments for episode 10.
Instead of jockeying and politicking
and pondering and posturing and debating
for three to four months,
we're just in do mode now.
And when you're in do mode,
you (bleeping) done.
It's fun that we're
producing a piece of content
that allows people to
learn in a different way.
It's unbelievable that
I've been writing books
and doing keynotes and making videos
and putting out 175 episodes.
And interview after interview.
I mean, it must be thousands of videos now
on YouTube of me
talking about the hustle.
And I guess I'm intrigued,
and I'm really speaking to you guys now,
all these other personalities have created
a scenario where I don't think
you guys believe anymore.
And I think what DailyVee's doing
and I'd like to challenge
my contemporaries,
thought leaders, people that write books,
people that wanna sell
seminars and courses
and monthly retainers to audiences.
I challenge them, I challenge you guys
to put out your DailyVee's.
I think this is exciting.
I think proving to the market.
I mean, I'm excited that DRock has to now,
and you know what I like,
the timestamp on Snapchat too,
'cause I get to really prove it.
I guess 'cause you can put
a timestamp of anything.
But it's dark.
I'm excited that,
Mike what time did we start today, 6:15?
- What's up?
- [Gary] We start at 6:15 today, right?
- Yes, six, yeah.
- Yeah, six for me.
I'm excited about the 5:45 wakeup.
I was excited 'cause me and AJ ended up
a little early, like my 10:15 starting
for my next meeting.
I didn't realize that people
thought it wasn't true.
And that's the truth.
And that's the truth for so many of you
watchin' right now.
Ya didn't think it was true.
Ya didn't think it was true
that they were 15, 16 hours a day.
You thought they were hyperbolized
and they were eight or nine.
You didn't realize every
minute was something.
You didn't realize that it's every day,
always, forever.
And not that this is for everybody.
It surely has eliminated the luck thing.
And what I don't think people realize is
this has been going on every day
for the last seven years at this pace.
Every day.
Every single day.
2000 days in a row.
Just, ya know, pounding
and grinding and hustling.
Big client to AJ and I strategizing to
investment opportunity
coming up right now.
Where do you think all
these answers come from?
You think they come
from kicks and giggles?
You think I'm sitting
for an hour on a beach
listening to somebody else's podcast
and regurgitating?
Because I know who's
regurgitating my shit.
I know who you are.
I watch it.
I get it.
I understand.
And I watch and I get and I understand
because I'm putting the work.
Because in between when DRock's
lookin' for b-roll right now,
I'm on my phone.
I'm answering, I'm reading.
I'm figuring out.
I'm consuming the market.
And so the nice feeling is
I thought some of this
stuff that I'm feeling
over the last three weeks with DailyVee
would happen in my
60's, and 70's, and 80's
when the results would just prove out.
But I didn't realize the
power that storytelling,
what this is gonna do.
First I was probably weirdly early on,
I've already said this on the show,
disappointed that people
were so surprised,
but now I'm excited because
there's a separation that
this has allowed for me
and I like it.
I like that people are startin' to realize
that I'm different,
mainly because it's selfish for me,
but it also allows people
to not be disappointed.
One of the most powerful things
that are going on right now
is how many people like,
"Oh, okay, I shouldn't be having
"Gary type results because
"I'm putting in half the work."
(mumbling)
We're now at 13, 14, 15.
Of course if you're
gonna work seven hours.
Oh by the way, I didn't
take an hour lunch.
Oh by the way, I didn't take 15 minutes
to watch some bullshit.
And oh the way, I didn't
have a 22-minute talk.
And by the way, I didn't have to take
a 5 PM beer, ever.
Ever, not today.
Not for the next 7000
episodes of DailyVee.
Because right now, you
didn't believe it at all.
And right now it's only 10 or 11 episodes,
but (chuckling).
God willing, we'll get old DRock.
I wish I did this seven years ago.
I wish I got to see the last seven years,
every minute, every day,
always, forever.
- I regurgitate your content.
- I know you do.
(laughing)
We know, Mike.
- [Mike] But it comes from the heart.
- I get it.
(laughing)
Listen, if it come from
the heart, it's all okay.